health officials seem to think it is
only a matter of time until the corona
virus starts to spread through
communities here in the United States
the Centers for Disease Control says it
is preparing medical personnel on how to
contain the spread of its flu-like
illness so far 34 coronavirus cases have
been confirmed in the US but there have
been more than 76,000 worldwide the vast
majority in China and overnight there
was a huge surge of cases in South Korea
more than 22-hundred people around the
world have died Debora patta is in Tokyo
where the disease is now threatening the
2020 Olympics which are still months
away
good morning Japan has been a pains to
stress that the Saar Olympics will not
be disrupted by the corona virus
outbreak but they've come under fire for
mismanaging the quarantine on the
diamond princess Japan has already
invested more than 28 billion dollars in
infrastructure for the Olympics and
there's around six billion dollars in
sponsorship at stake melinda
coefficience insist the games will not
be canceled or postponed but experts
point out that the government doesn't
have a plan B if the virus continues to
spread in this country other than to
cross their fingers and hope and debates
in time for the Olympics in July their
handling of the quarantine process on
the now notorious diamond princess has
done little to restore public confidence
in their crisis management ability and
the ship has become the site of the
largest cluster of infections outside
China globally new pockets of infections
have also sprung up with the most
troubling in South Korea the majority of
them linked to a church in Daegu a woman
in her 60s attended a church service
before testing positive for the virus at
least one-thousand worshipers have been
confined to their homes schools have
been closed and residents have been told
to avoid mass gatherings the US military
base in Daegu has restricted the
movement of all personnel there there
are no cases confirmed amongst the
Americans but the measures have been
implemented out of an abundance of
caution
CBS this morning Saturday Debora patta
Tokyo Japan